hey everyone this is Steve Electro with
collider and I am thrilled to be with
the people behind the Wonder
um I want to start with congratulations
on the movie and thank you so much for
coming into our studio today uh I have
tons of questions about your movie I
promise but I like throwing a few
curveballs right at the beginning which
hopefully you have not been asked
um if someone is actually and it could
be this project but if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
directed before what is the first thing
you want them watching and why and if
someone has never read anything that
you've read I mean anything that you've
written before what is the first thing
you want them reading and why
well who am I to to judge
um but maybe maybe a good
way in would be a fantastic woman which
is a film from 2017
um why
because I I guess it's it has many
elements that my other films do have
um mainly like putting at the center of
the narrative a character that should
not be at the center of a narrative
according to what Society
thinks or tends to think so maybe that
would be my recommendation
that was your film that made me want you
to direct the Wonder
um I would probably pick
um room which I wrote as a novel and
then Lenny Abramson made as a film
um because for some reason that
character of a child who's grown up in a
locked room seems to hook everyone just
the widest variety of readers and
audiences seem to care about that kid in
his situation
if you could get the financing to make
anything that you want what would you
make and why
this is usually the question like if you
have that dream project you've been
trying to kick around
I don't know what to answer sorry
I have a big musical so if you in your
pocket have the budget for that you know
20 person singing and dancing musical
that's that's what I want to make next I
hate asking the generic question
but
most of the people watching this will
have not seen the movie yet how have you
been describing the movie to friends and
family or how would you like to describe
them the the how you know what I mean
well
um the Wonder is uh the story about a
nurse an English nurse who is summoned
to
buy a group of notables to watch to
observe a young girl a girl 11 years old
who is allegedly surviving without food
for months so the town is sort of like
upside down because of this situation
they have to uh bring things back to
normal
and the nurse thinks is going to uncover
The hoax in 10 minutes but then
that's not what happens and uh as she
becomes more and more fascinated by the
girl and
a sort of like love for her
emerges
um she will also have will have to
understand if something more ominous is
uh is really happening there and that
nurse a rationalist
scientifically minded woman
that starts the story kind of like
looking down at these superstitious
people ends up doing the wildest Things
that are somehow
Way Beyond the limits of reason
um in order to save herself and and
hopefully save save the girl too
I thought you did a fantastic job uh
helming and doing this movie and I'm
just curious what is it what is it like
for a director showing
um what was it like for you watching it
for the first time I'm curious if you
were on set and what that you know what
I mean how nervous are you the the when
you hit play in the screening room you
know what I mean I was on set for about
10 different days of the filming and I
was particularly moved that these were
the Landscapes of my childhood and yet I
was seeing them afreshed through
Sebastian's eyes and I found that the
cinematography and the directorial
decisions about the landscape and so on
um
brought something absolutely new to it
that I hadn't seen there while I was
writing the book
if I'm not mistaken could be wrong but
this was Netflix's Netflix UK's first uh
exactly yeah
um which is awesome
um and can you sort of talk about
working with Netflix because I've spoken
to a lot of filmmakers and they all
praise uh you know the relationship with
them in terms of the creative freedom
and giving good notes I mean in this
case was was the same
um they were the only ones that were
willing to
uh bet for the film
uh in a strong way so we could make the
film we wanted to make
um so I'll always be grateful for that
because
um there were other versions of the film
uh were probably the results would have
been less um
I don't know there's something about the
visual
an attempt for visual Splendor that the
film has let me just say that it it's
very cinematic it feels like a movie and
I think it comes from the budget you had
um and maybe if you had told this in
three weeks or if you know much like a
schedule you would not have those shots
that you have yeah exactly exactly so so
yeah they were they were great and it
was also an honor to be the first
um
film that they fully supported
I'm talking about the UK slate
um so yeah it was it's been a great
relationship and I think we're all
I'm happy to have made the thing we
wanted to make something that I found
very interesting
um was the way and I I'm just going to
talk about the opening was how you open
the movie and I'm curious uh what was
the motivation for starting the film the
way that you do I don't know how much
you want to say so yeah not too much um
I call it the the frame
um
well
I guess that because it's a film about
belief systems you know it is a theme
about believing and how much we need to
believe either by default or choice in
stories in order to
live and cross life there's no way you
can
inhabit this world without with without
some sort of narrative
um
that gives the world a meaning that
might not have
we don't know
um so in this story
um belief systems collide
you have science
as the greatest belief system as I
consider it
um the greatest conquer conquered by
conquest by Humanity it's a belief
system that holds doubt in its heart is
willing to expand change and adapt as
opposed to
other belief systems like in this case
what is represented in the film via
Faith which is people that found the
truth and are not willing to move from
there
so these things Collide um I like the
way you use Collide Collide it's because
in Spanish we use a similar word and
that's the one I know that works uh so I
just wanted the viewer to be aware that
they were going to be believing in the
film
um just like the characters believe in
their stories and I just wanted to hear
and there gently reminded reminded them
to
that they were believing
and the mechanisms they were using are
not dissimilar to the ones that the
characters are using and
and
um and therefore maybe as they watched
the film they could
wonder you know what they believe in
and if they believe by choice or or
default and if those beliefs can be
expanded
adapted are they elastic or rigid
what you grasp from the novel even is
that the story is very meta anyway
to observe you know it's it says to the
audience like what would you be taken in
by you know how would you interpret this
you know and and to observe something
and not intervene is a decision in
itself so it the whole story really is
about the process of being an audience
yeah that's very true and I think that's
one of the things that made me want to
do a film I loved that sort of like meta
element of the novel
um she's observing everyone else's
narratives
um
and then
and then in order to save the girl she
has to transcend her own
one of the things in the film
um in uh I don't know what the right
term is but you're zooming in or
dollying in a lot
um on a lot of shots and a lot of
characters can you sort of talk about
um the way where you like placing the
camera how you decided on those kinds of
shots
well you know one of the main
co-creators in this film is Ari Wagner
the cinematographer
um we do the entire film together a
couple of weeks before shooting after
finding the location so we we found the
calligraphy of the film
together and then um
we were we were looking for these long
shots uh
many things happen in just one shot the
camera is always moving it's sort of
like a winged camera
um we wanted that sort of like floating
state
uh dreamy a dreamy a dreamy World a
dreamy landscape a fable story uh in
which you are believing kind of kind of
approach and then the the camera is
always not always but usually pushing in
either
on dollies or cranes or there's only one
moment where when when it pushes back
which isn't at precisely at the
height of the climax of the film I I
like being a spoiler free since most
people you know have not seen it
um so I'm curious you've written
if which of your things that you've
written would you love to see adapted
um I'm working on a film adaptation of
my novel the pull of the Stars which is
set during the Spanish flu epidemic in a
in a labor Ward and I I'm relishing the
challenge of taking something so
physical and slow as birth and and
telling it cinematically in a way which
doesn't oversimplify it the way births
are usually shown on screen one of the
things it that streaming has uh given us
is the ability to series TV series are
very popular on streaming you know four
episodes Eight Episodes how do you
decide what
um what should be a series what should
be a movie and you know the the debate
between the two and I'm just curious
yeah I'm just as drawn to writing
probably not long form but many series
as features but I don't know there's
there's still something about the
momentum of a feature the idea that
people will watch it in just one block
and that there's a sort of unbearable
squeezing of the story into maybe an
hour and a half and for certain projects
I think only that that squeeze will
produce the kind of intensity I'm
looking for even though as a consumer
I'm a huge fan of miniseries uh I'm
always curious about the editing room or
the editing process because it's where
it all comes together so talk a little
bit about the challenges you faced when
you got in the editing room or um or you
know what you learned from friends and
family screenings that impacted the
finished film well I mean because it's a
very uh
precise and designed script in the sense
that
it's not that you can play around with
the structure too much in the edit
because it is it has elements of
suspense and it is about sort of this
investigation that she's going through
so the bits and pieces are slowly coming
together for her at the same time for
the viewer so it's it the room for the
room for
um
changing too much things wasn't there
but it was an extremely precise work I
mean we needed to
to kind of like dive in and uh what it's
a very precise edit editing that's what
I'm trying to say
um with Christina heatherington the
editor we yeah we I mean
it's one of the most difficult films
I've edited or are witnessed how it was
edited because I was there with her but
Christina did you know she she was
really the editor of course
um but what I'm trying to say it was uh
yeah it was it wasn't easy
to edit to find the right tone
um
the you know the the the precise the
more precise moment of each performance
and put them together in a way that they
would click and seem
effortless which is I guess the goal he
had to cut the scene in which I was an
extra which was clearly an agonizing
decision
um but I felt that gave my experience as
an extra uh the classic quality of being
an extra and doing all that work and not
ending up in the movie so I feel I've
really been an extra did you get to keep
the deleted scene do you have it at home
I have just a visual that made that's
all I was able to harvest of the raw
footage they gave me is the visuals of
me briefly walking past Florence Pew and
Kieran Hines yeah so that's a key
feature of my family video for the year
um what are you actually most excited a
little generic I apologize but what are
you most excited for people to see with
the film well we have this breakthrough
star who was 11 when we filmed Kila Lord
Cassidy I'm thrilled at our movie as
she's had other roles but our movie I
think will be the one that really brings
her to that world audience that she
absolutely deserves yeah she's she's
great I would say the performances in
general
um
um especially the two women at the
center like Florence Pugh it's really
she's a magnificent actress I consider
her to be incredible and uh she's the
heart of the film and the soul of the
film and and she has this dual with this
girl
um actual duel
um and they are both like challenging
each other and I think that's something
very special to watch because it's a
relationship that is quite unusual in a
film
so I think the two of them
that's exciting to share the film and so
people can have the chance to see them
both
yeah
um yeah in the arena she's a fantastic
actor did you cast her prior to her
getting the Marvel role or was it after
the Marvel role because her star has
really blown up in the last you know
year or two technically it was after the
Marvel role was shot
but before it was released so
I wouldn't say that was
at least for me a big part of the
equation it was more uh really coming
from the admiration
for her as an artist and
the quality she has that she's she makes
you want to be on her side
despite the fact that in the film she's
doing things that are that are quite
extreme and could be qualified at at
least as morally complex and you are
with her and that's because Florence is
all about
yeah like total integrity she has that
no completely I buy into what she's
selling on screen uh absolutely uh we've
been asking everyone coming into our
studio the same few questions I'm going
to ask you before I let you go
um what TV series would you love to
guest Direct in what TV series would you
love to guest right
I most recently saw under the banner of
heaven and I can imagine plunging into
that world writing wise
I um maybe if there's a new season of
Mad Men
I would love to yeah eventually uh yeah
be there uh what movie do you think
you've seen the most
in my in my life yeah
as a teenager I watched Out of Africa
seven times in cinemas just worshiping
the two of them imagining myself somehow
in between
um Robert Redford and Meryl Streep
well I filmed that I keep you know
watching and watching over the years
since 2001.
it's just endless it's a classic in the
sense that it will always be young
and also every time you watch it you can
get something new absolutely it's
amazing it's probably the film along
with vertigo
yeah I heard Hitchcock he's okay
you know um on that note I need to wrap
with the two of you and I'm just going
to say congratulations on the film and I
really look forward to it being out in
cinemas and on Netflix so people can
experience it uh you guys did a
tremendous job with us and thank you so
much for coming in to our studio thank
you so much for having us thank you for
the technical questions about camera
movements you don't get much of that
these days fantastic